[music]
Hey it's me, Destin. Welcome back to Smarter Every Day. This is different, it's really
a big deal. I have been invited to go to
the White House to sit down with the
President of the United States of
America for 10 to 12 minutes to discuss
issues that matter to me and matter to
you. This is a huge honour and I want
to get it right. The interview is framed
as a response to the State of the Union
address which you can watch on Tuesday
at 9 p.m. Eastern time at youtube.com/whitehouse
I would love for this to be
different. I want to ask questions about
scientific topics, something I care about. What about the personal things about
being the president? Wouldn't that be cool? We have a huge opportunity here. The
format is going to be really cool, they
created a small version of my office that's
going to be there at the White House so
we can just hang out and talk like we
always do, except the President is there. We shot a short promo for it out in LA and I'll
introduce you to the other two YouTube creators that's gonna be there with me.
Okay so we're in LA and they have created sets for us. This is the Smarter Every Day set
You got Ingrid
and sWooZie
- My good side. -[laughs]
This is where I'm at. [whispering] Gotta be quiet.
["Hail to the Chief"-style music]
Ingird, you've got a lot of beauty stuff and
many other things right?
- And life things, you know?
[music]
There is no other country on Earth where
something like this could happen and I'm
extremely excited and honored to be
taking part. So, here's how we're going to come up with questions:
Number one: click that link right there. It'll create a Tweet and automatically
populate the "YouTube Asks Obama" hashtag. Do that! I'll be filtering through those.
Number two: leave an intelligent, respectful comment on this video or number three: go to
the Ask Reddit thread I'm going to be making. People are going to be upvoting and downvoting;
we got to get the best questions in front
of the Commander-in-Chief. I'm most
excited about your science questions, and about your fun questions for the President.
Anyway, please check those out and watch the thing. It's going to be live on January 15th
at youtube.com/whitehouse. So
that's it! I'm Destin, let's get smarter
every day, together, at the White House
with the President of the United States. Have a good one.
[music]